[Música]
olá
essa foi melhor no início eu consegui
pensar por que eu tenho que admitir pra
vocês gente eu não sei fazer falantes
não sei fazer uma palestra de ted é a
primeira vez que eu tô aqui e eu não vou
nem tentar disfarçar o nervosismo eu vou
à rua assumir eu vou contar com a
simpatia de vocês porque esse dia é é
uma honra pra mim porque várias vezes na
minha vida o ted acabou me salvando de
um lugar muito obscuro
curiosamente a primeira palestra do dia
foi do ted gente porque rio foi o
primeiro pede que eu participei eu
estava lá naquela platéia e aquele dia
foi decisivo para eu não sair da
faculdade foi a força que eu precisava
pra conseguir terminar naquele dia eu
recebi muita inspiração para eu
conseguir fazer o projeto final e aí
quando ele me convidou pra falar com
vocês a gente até tinha visto alguma a
possibilidade de conversar sobre algumas
outras experiências mas do fundo do meu
coração eu quis que eu conseguisse
passar pra vocês algo que fosse
realmente importante então eu não vou
falar de algum conhecimento que vocês
nunca ouviram eu vou falar alguma coisa
de coração para coração alguma coisa que
eu espero que ajude vocês no desafio
chamado vida que vocês têm agora e como
eu já admite que eu não sei fazer
palestra eu quero chamar memória de
vocês uma coisa no início quando vocês
eram criança com certeza
cantávamos aqui é bem chata
já algumas pessoas viram já sabe né
vocês podem ajudar por favor não sabe
não sabe vai ter que aprender
[Música]
mas é difícil
um belo dia você vai ter que aprender a
salva de palmas na percussão
agradeço a colaboração de vocês porque a
primeira coisa vocês então já sabem que
tipo de senso de humor que eu tenho no
meu orgulho gente mas eu sou assim e aí
é uma das questões fundamentais que eu
quero trabalhar com vocês hoje é se eu
erro eu sou burro
se eu ia forma de fazer a melhor
introdução de palestras do ted na vida
eu sou burra
se eu deixasse o microfone caí aqui no
chão eu seria burro
foi por isso que eu pedi isso aqui gente
porque é menos um problema que eu posso
entrar aqui no palco
e outra coisa porque eu me sinto a xuxa
então eu riu de mim mesmo então ajuda a
gente tende a encarar o erro de formas
diferentes depende do contexto e eu
quero voltar agora o contexto andar de
bicicleta enquanto a gente cantava
musiquinha com certeza não foi andar de
bicicleta que veio na cabeça de vocês
com certeza não provavelmente não foi
nenhuma situação feliz mas pensa só
quando a gente anda de bicicleta ou
quando a gente aprende a andar de
bicicleta
a gente sabe que vai cair a gente não
espera alguém que a gente está ensinando
acertar de primeira
a gente sabe que a pessoa vai cair a
gente já separa gaza e mel chocolate e
dependendo da intimidade até uma câmera
para filmar e depois de mostrar a
posteridade não é assim ninguém se cobra
em acertar sempre andando de bicicleta
até quando você é mais velho se você
cair de bicicleta tudo bem
agora quando você erra numa prova
[Música]
quem é que já se sentiu profundamente
desesperado ao olhar uma página cheia de
questões que não conseguia responder
[Música]
é terrível é como se fosse culpa sua
você não estudou o suficiente você não
sabe
e agora aí é um sinal de que a gente
gosta de aprender só porque as
habilidades esportivas são desenvolvidas
em um nível que ninguém consegue
imaginar
tem gente que cola só por diversão mas
tem gente que sabe que é uma necessidade
e começa a desenvolver os estratagemas
tão tão tão elaborados que a gente não é
possível chamar essa pessoa de burra não
é
ela só está aplicando mal inteligência
dela como é que a gente sabe que a gente
não está conseguindo passar o conteúdo
de uma forma clara quando chega no dia
da prova começa a ver a galera pessoa em
grupo
sim você e deus conta com isso tem
consulta assim a sua memória
o agente o professor por dentro não é
porque a gente sabe que a gente não está
preparada a gente sabe que vai ter
aqueles eram na prova a gente sabe que
vai dar bronca em casa todas as
situações
a crueldade é nem sempre isso acontece
com os alunos relapsos
às vezes os bons alunos passam por isso
quem nunca se esforçou pra caramba e
tirou essa nota baixa
obrigado pela colaboração gente isso
ajuda muito
eu trouxe essa fórmula porque com
certeza a maioria de vocês já viu isso
aqui né
alguém sabe me dizer o nome disso como
show palmas por favor
[Música]
maravilha o que é curioso
muita gente quando olha para isso só
lembra disso aqui
[Música]
galera não é assim que se decora quando
eu fiz uma experiência quando estava
propondo o o tema da minha palestra que
foi perguntar se lembra qual formou do
sorvete
aí o pessoal lembrava a aoc lembra pra
que serve a fórmula do sorvete ninguém
lembrava lembrava que tinha o sorvete e
os orbitam mas o resto parece que a
pessoa tinha apagado da memória porque
eu concordo com você que às vezes a
gente tem que fazer uma escolha de tanta
coisa que a gente tem que colocar para
dentro às vezes a gente só escolhe
decorar e aí a gente fica nessa nesse
dilema com o tempo que a gente tem com
energia que a gente tem a gente vai
aprender ou a gente vai passar de série
e vamos ser sinceros isso vai para a
faculdade pra vida
[Música]
isso merece uma citação da gnr gol no
qual ela já foi citado aqui mais cedo em
outras palestras é o meu tédio preferido
na vida é jogando por um mundo melhor
onde ela faz essa comparação entre essa
face que eu acho maravilhosa que a face
da vitória épica é ela disse um
fotógrafo registrou o exato momento em
que um jogador de videogame tava sabe
fazendo o que era impossível ele estava
canalizando toda a energia dele toda
sabedoria dele tudo o que havia de
melhor nas suas estratégias para
conseguir aquela vitória que ele mesmo
duvidava que no jogo fazia muito sentido
mas na vida real não
ela compara isso com essa cara de eu não
sou bom viver que acaba que a gente faz
na maioria das vezes quando a gente vai
estudar
eu não sou bom estudar isso o problema é
às vezes a gente em internaliza aquela
maldita daquela musiquinha tão
profundamente que a gente fica velho ea
gente não desapego de certas
resistências com algum tema
então não vou aprender física
não não vou aprender inglês não não vou
porque eu não consigo
eu fico triste às vezes quando eu até
pessoas familiares em minhas dizendo não
redação não é pra mim nunca foi e aí
voltamos a essa fórmula zinha a gente
talvez por medo talvez por receio por
vários motivos a gente associa mais a
sorvete do que andar de bicicleta não
faz mais sentido se eu estou calculando
o posicionamento se eu tenho razões de
velocidade bicicleta não é sorvete mas
porque a gente faz isso com a gente
mesmo
como a gente consegue transpor os
sentimentos que a gente tem no videogame
o sentimento que a gente tem no nosso
hobby para a escola nos jogos
os desafios apresentados estão no seu
nível de dificuldade é isso que a gente
fala você não chega na fase do boss do
chefão sem antes se armar
você sabe que você está preparado para
aquilo diferente do que acontece às
vezes na nossa vida acadêmica porque
teoricamente a gente está no 2º ano por
exemplo a gente pode receber aqueles
desafios porque a gente já passou pelo
primeiro ano mas isso a gente passou
pelo primeiro ano decorando e esquecendo
tudo depois da prova
é um ciclo sem fim que a gente faz com
isso e aí tem até algumas situações
interessantes se você bota a mão na
massa e prática alguém que já fez esse
experimento de acender a lâmpada na
batata limão laranja ou acender botar
uma buzina alguma coisa assim
a minha pergunta o que você fez um
experimento você conseguiu reproduzir o
protocolo você se perde você se perde
numa floresta
você consegue com tudo que você encontra
ali criar uma bateria para alimentar o
seu celular e conseguir fazer uma
ligação que salvar sua vida porque a
gente não associa naturalmente o
conhecimento que a gente recebe com a
vida real
qual é a parede que tem no meio disso e
como é que a gente quebra a gente quer
jovens inovadores
a gente tá aqui falando de inovação o
dia inteiro mas a gente está ensinando
eles a decorar coisas para passar
ano a desvendar o mundo e aqui ele
aprende aquele prazer de aprender alguma
coisa nova quando vocês com certeza vem
uma série nova um filme novo uma música
nova prova alguma comida gostosa já se
espalhou para os amigos que aprendeu
alguma coisa porque isso não acontece
quando a gente descobre alguma coisa que
a gente está estudando sucesso hoje por
um estudante é passar de ano com boas
notas ou ser capaz de entender a
realidade e até resolver um problema do
mundo real o que vocês consideram um
estudante bem sucedido
isso diz muito sobre quem nós somos
nesse processo educacional o que a gente
quer desvendar na escola a gente quer
desvendar alguma coisa na escola eu
quero eu comecei com design
a explicação foi maravilhosa então não
precisa me até isso de novo mas é o que
eu acredito e eu decidir embarcar nessa
no processo educacional
então é isso que eu quero fazer e parte
do meu tempo eu gasto tentando fazer as
crianças e os adolescentes mudarem a
mentalidade de estou fazendo porque o
professor pediu pra eu estou fazendo o
meu projeto de descoberta e é difícil
pra caramba
é difícil porque não entendem que a faz
parte do processo mostrar pra eles que
rafa as partes muito difícil será que
será que vocês sabem que rafa parte do
processo
vocês sentem liberdade e segurança para
expor os seus erros
vocês conseguem rir dos seus erros
todo mundo rico local de bicicleta mas
vocês conseguem ri quando você não
acerta aquela equação se consegue disso
vocês conseguem encontrar apoio no
colega ou vai ter aquela musiquinha
maldita quando na cabeça
vocês entendem que frustração faz parte
do caminho
aquela situação deu tudo errado
maravilha você aprendeu como não fazer é
lindo quando a gente ouve citação de
benjamin franklin
ah eu tenho 10 mil formas não aprendeu
já é que eu sei de como não fazer uma
lâmpada na nossa vida a gente tem essa
região
e a gente vê então para o faça você
mesmo como a chave que eu tô vendo pra
gente poder aprender de verdade na
prática e não esquecer de fazer quebrar
essa parede que divide o conhecimento
que a gente sabe da leitura do nosso
mundo mas não faça sozinho eu estou
muito feliz muito orgulhosa de poder tá
vendo isso nesse movimento make na rede
latina por exemplo onde eu pude ver por
exemplo a construção de uma casa usando
máquinas cnc um projeto de barcelona e
vendo a abstração se materializando eu
consigo entender as coisas melhor pra
vocês terem idéia o conhecimento ele
está tão acessível se vocês tiverem
interessados que a gente tem um exemplo
do joão que queria tocar violão e os
colegas de escola que decidiram buscar
conhecimento pra fazer isso pra ele
existe um projeto chamado live in the
future onde eles disponibilizam modelos
gratuitos para download de quem quiser
pra poder fazer e aí eles puderam fazer
isso a gente tem site como instructables
que tem detalhamento de passo a passo
para executar e eles puderam fazer então
essa transição entre a seria tão legal
que o meu amigo pudesse tocar violão pra
ok eu vou descobrir como fazer isso eu
vou chegar lá eu vou estudar e eu vou
conseguir
nesse processo eu e os meus colegas do
laboratório fomos duramente
facilitadores
esses são os dentes e tem que pesquisar
esses são os caminhos que você pode ir e
eles foram e eles conseguiram
e qualquer coisa provavelmente que vocês
quiserem fazer vocês vão encontrar um
caminho nesse mundo maker
até hoje sempre que me dar um exemplo a
gente achou pesquisando vocês podem
encontrar nos laboratórios maker da vida
inclusive aqui no innovation e aprender
ferramentas suficientes para poderem
botar
essa idéia no mundo real e testar
colocar esses protótipos a prova e ver
se funcionam e nessa forma vocês então
aprendem aplicando nesse caso anatomia
geometria mecânica design empatia
resiliência trabalho em equipe
planejamento de produção e diversas
outras qualidades que você precisa como
pessoa mas o que vocês têm interesse em
aprender essa pergunta fundamental
porque é só quando vocês acharem isso
que vocês vão se dedicavam debruçar e
vão fazer o conhecimento aflorar
se o projeto é seu e você se importa
você vai estudar como fazer melhor
se você errar está tudo bem você vai
querer aprender uma maneira de resolver
cerro
a gente sempre fala uma coisa lá no
laboratório tudo bem se você errar mas
por favor não esposa o laboratório
isso nunca aconteceu então tem dado
muito certo e as pessoas com aquela cara
eu posso mesmo eu posso botar a mão
dessa impressora 3d
eu posso botar a mão nesse corte a laser
você não vai me impedir de tocar no
estômago e na caríssima não e quando
chega naquele momento de eu fiz essa
carinha dessa menina é carinho que eu
vejo na é essa face que eu vejo as
pessoas depois que elas conseguem
concluir a primeira peça delas e é o que
eu desejo profundamente pra todos vocês
em qualquer coisa que vocês fizerem que
vocês tenham esse prazer essa alegria de
terem realizado algo eu acho que com
essa carinha agora por ter conseguido
concluir esse ted muito obrigado gente
[Música]